clairement vidé de ses milliers de
pèlerins mais surtout de ces millions de
touristes qui affluent chaque année
pendant le mois du ramadan dans cette
cité islamique construite au 9e siècle
première mosquée d'afrique depuis le
coronavirus bien sûr comme toutes les
villes du pays la communauté de carvin
dû s'adapter fermer ces mosquées fermées
et ses commerces alors comment font-ils
pour vivre cette période du ramadan en
plein confinement quels changements y at
il pour les religieux les habitants et
surtout les commerçants de la cité
gardien de la grande mosquée de kairouan
l'imam al rosie connaît chaque recoin de
ce haut lieu de diffusion de la
civilisation arabo musulmane depuis 670
ces colonnes antiques et son imposant
minaret voit défiler des milliers de
fidèles venus des quatre coins de
l'afrique
depuis quelques semaines il règne un
calme inhabituel dans cette vieille cité
islamique une première dans l'histoire
de la ville je n'ai jamais vécu une
telle situation dans la vie et pourtant
je suis un enfant du pays
je suis né à deux pas de la mosquée je
n'avais jamais vu celui aussi vide et ça
me rend très triste les flammes en temps
normal pendant le ramadan la cour de la
mosquée est remplie de fidèles
mais mon sale les courants de ne trouver
aucune place pour prier il y a tellement
de monde qu'on doit aménager des espaces
à l'extérieur de la mosquée dans les
différentes places tout autour de
l'édifice valin mais non c est qu il est
évident que de tels rassemblements
constitue un réel danger en cette
période de coronavirus un danger pour la
santé des fidèles et c'est pour cette
raison que les autorités ont pris cette
décision à savoir fermer les mosquées du
pays
la grande mosquée aux ruelles exigu et
coloré de la médina le coronavirus a
plongé la ville dans un calme quasi
monastique d'effervescence a laissé
place au silence
au grand dam des habitants de la vieille
cité aghlabites
j'ai vu beaucoup de visiteurs qui
étaient étonnés en venant chez nous
avant la rupture du jeûne les rues sont
désertes mais dès le coucher du soleil
juste après que les gens ont dîné c'est
un autre monde et ces mêmes visiteurs
deviennent alors surpris il règne alors
une effervescence incroyable dans la
cité une ambiance de festival de
carnaval avec beaucoup d'animations avec
cette épidémie de coronavirus plus
personne ne sort la nuit et la cité
plonge alors dans un silence étrange
beaucoup perturbé les kairouanais et a
complètement changé leurs habitudes
c'est un vrai choc pour nous tous pour
les commerçants de la cité et les
restaurateurs
le mois du ramadan représente 30% de
leur chiffre d'affaires
tapie confiseries ou encore poterie
c'est tout un pan de l'économie de la
cité qui s'est effondré avec la crise du
coronavirus un coup dur pour le tissu
économique de la région
résigné dans la tente d'un plan des du
gouvernement c'est dans ce restaurant
pendant le ramadan nous avons l'habitude
d'accueillir de nombreux visiteurs et
fidèles venus des quatre coins du pays
en plus des familles de la ville
ils viennent profiter du repas des
festivités de la grande mosquée de la
prière du soir
mais cette année tout a changé avec
cette épidémie l'icij emploie 28
personnes donc 28 familles qui sont au
chômage aujourd'hui et malgré ça
aujourd'hui je leur ai verser leur
salaire tout comme le mois dernier
j'espère juste que cette situation ne va
pas durer car financièrement on ne
pourra pas continuer comme ça jamais
dans l'histoire de kerho on n'aurait
imaginé un tel scénario
cette année le ramadan a dû s'adapter
aux cours aux navires us et la cité se
réinventer alors que le gouvernement a
annoncé un déconfinement partiel dès le
3 mai prochain
les habitants de kairon espère soufflé
de nouveau et relancer progressivement
l'économie de la vieille cité islamique